Hello, we have just restocked the Microcosmos
Microscope over at microcosmos.store.
And we now have two models available, one
that comes with achromatic objectives, and
the another that comes with plan achromatic
objectives.
And if you’ve previously purchased a Microcosmos
Microscope and would like to upgrade your
objectives from achromatic to plan, we have
a 4 pack of plan objectives on sale, as well
two brand new 20x and 60x plan objectives.
You can get those all now at microcosmos.store.
We’re going to get right to the point because
we are just too excited about today’s episode.
If you’ve been following James, our master
of microscopes, on some of his other platforms,
then you know what’s coming.
You know that James has published his first
academic paper, which was co-authored by
Dr. Demetra Andreou and James’ mentor, Professor
Genoveva F. Esteban.
If you want to find it, just look for the
article titled “The Extraordinarily Rare
Ciliate Legendrea loyezae” in the journal
Protist.
We’ll leave a link for it down below.
The paper is, as you might be able to tell
from the title, about this extraordinarily
rare ciliate that you see on the screen
now called Legendrea loyezae.
Just how rare is this ciliate?
It’s so rare that before James stumbled
on some of his own, it had only been reported
by four other people, ever.
There are a vast number of microbe species
in the world.
So many, in fact, that it seems like a miracle
that we are able to find the same species twice.
Some of these species are incredibly prolific,
reproducing at rates that make them impossible
to ignore under the microscope.
But then there are the microbes who turn up
once in a blue moon, like a mythical creature
of the microcosmos whose life seems to exist
only in a few lines of text and the rare illustrations
that preserve them.
The first record of Legendrea loyezae’s
existence came in 1908, from a French scientist
named Emmanuel Fauré-Fremiet.
He had been gathering samples from a pond
near Paris, studying the mud for what he described
as “infusoria”, a name once used to describe
microbes.
And among the organisms he found were just
a few of these oval-ish creatures, with one
elongated macronucleus and roughly 20 tentacles
of varying length that branch out from their bodies.
He named the creature Legendrea loyezae, though
he never explained why.
Only six years later, a Swiss biologist named
Eugene Penard reported finding Legendrea loyezae
in his own samples, this time from Geneva.
But he didn’t just stop with Legendrea loyezae.
Penard found six other species that he believed
should belong to the genus, including this
one, which he named Legendrea bellerophon.
There were a few characteristics that made
Penard consider this a new, separate species.
But the most important factor were Legendrea
bellerophon’s tentacles, which Penard described
as really more like “sessile pimples”
that could extend and retract.
In comparison, Legendrea loyezae were not capable
of the controlled extension
that Legendrea bellerophon are.
Instead, their tentacles trail behind as they
swim through the water.
Alfred Kahl, the prolific documenter of ciliate
life, reported his description of Legendrea
loyezae in 1930.
But after that, they seemed to go unnoticed
in the microcosmos until 2014, when a microscopist
named Martin Kreutz found them lurking in
German ponds.
And across all of these descriptions were
slight contradictions, differences in how
they perceived the cell’s morphology that
were difficult to resolve with so few observations.
But even in those large gaps of time where
scientists weren’t finding Legendrea loyezae,
they were not forgotten.
In 1967, the scientist A.W.
Jankowski decided to take an ax to the Legendrea
genus, splitting it into three.
The distinction was based on the placement
of the organism’s tentacles.
Legendrea like Legendrea loyezae who had tentacles
at the end of the cell would remain Legendrea.
Those who had tentacles only halfway in a
row around the cell would become Lacerus.
And those who had extendable tentacles in
a row that goes around the cell would be called
Thysanomorpha.
And that’s how Legendrea bellerophon became
Thysanomorpha bellerophon.
It’s not clear why Jankowski made this decision
to split Legendrea into three genera, nor
is it clear why it was accepted in the official
taxonomic codes.
Jankowski didn’t seem to have made any observations
of his own to decide these differences, instead
using the discrepancies in the rare, existing
observations to make vast changes in taxonomy,
without accounting for other possibilities.
But that brings us to 2021 and the discovery
of another possibility.
More specifically, it brings us to James,
equipped with a plastic bottle, a microscope,
and an endless devotion to his craft.
Visiting two lakes around Warsaw, James carefully
gathered samples from the bottom of the lakes
and stored them in the dark, with lids shut
tight to minimize the amount of oxygen coming
in so that the anaerobic organisms that live
in these sediments could thrive.
And when he went to see what was hiding within
his samples, he found four Legendrea loyezae.
He immediately recognized it from the pages
of his beloved ciliate reference books and
was thrilled to tell his mentor, Professor
Esteban.
But the most surprising thing would come later,
in a microscope slide James sealed off with
petroleum jelly so that he could watch this
Legendrea loyezae for longer.
He’d been watching it swim around, its tentacles
trailing behind.
And he kept the slide in a humidity chamber and
returned to it over several days, watching
as it settled down among some debris.
It was clearly alive because there was movement
in its cytoplasm, but it just didn’t move,
even when James lightly tapped the slide or
shined strong light on it.
But after four days, something strange happened.
This green euglenid wandered close to the
Legendrea, too close, apparently, for the
Legendrea’s comfort, causing it to contract
its tentacles.
We still don’t know what exactly set the
Legendrea into action, but the most likely
explanation is that the euglenid was releasing
oxygen into the water,
discomforting the anaerobic Legendrea.
What caught James and Professor Esteban’s
notice was that Legendrea loyezae seemed to
not only control the length of its tentacles,
but also the location.
And as they extended and contracted their
tentacles, the organism’s shape changed.
When extended, the tentacles appeared towards
the side of the swollen organism.
When contracted, the tentacles sprouted out
from the end of a heart-shaped cell.
No one had ever observed this tentacle extension
in Legendrea loyezae before.
And more importantly, this movement seems
to explain the differences between the descriptions
of Legendrea loyezae made by earlier scientists.
The different shapes they observed were likely
Legendrea loyezae in different states of tentacle contraction.
And this is really meaningful because it muddles the
reasoning behind Jankowski’s division of
the Legendrea, which was derived in part on
a static understanding of the tentacles.
And as James argues in the paper, it means
that Thysanomorpha bellerophon should become
Legendrea bellerophon once more.
These observations that James made with his
microscope revealed a lot about a rare species.
But there are depths that the microscope cannot
reach, information hidden in places we need
other techniques to reach.
We’ll talk about that in our next episode.
And who knows.
With more observation and more data, perhaps
there will be more species reverted back to
the Legendrea genus.
Because that’s the point of science.
There is no end to what we know and what we
will learn.
There is simply a patient dedication to the
work.
To visiting the same pond week after week.
To watching the same sample day after day.
To digging through old books and forgotten
texts until they are embedded in memory.
We do love quoting a microscopist here on
Journey to the Microcosmos.
So perhaps we should pay tribute to our own
master of microscopes and the ending of his paper.
We hope that the study here presented inspires
the readership to spend more time looking
through a microscope and reminding them that
science is done to subside the mind’s curiosity,
not incite discord in one’s rather short
lifespan.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
No matter what we’re doing, we are always
communicating.
It’s how we make meaning of our surroundings
and interactions.
Communication is ingrained in our daily interactions
and even if you feel like you’re a great
communicator, it is still important to understand
that communication is a really complex social
process that can change depending on a wide
array of factors!
And that’s why there is “Study Hall:
Human Communication”, the series where
they explore communication, unpack why it
matters in our lives, and teach you how to
become an even better communicator.
They’ll walk you through the skills needed
to be a good friend, student, employee, leader,
and problem-solver, and help you better understand
how communication can impact your relationships
with people.
So check out Study Hall: Human Communication
at the link in the description.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons, they support this channel
as we explore this wonderful world of ours
that has so many secrets in it, that are just
waiting to be uncovered.
And in this video we got to talk about a secret
that was uncovered by our Master of Microscopes.
Which is really remarkable, so I wanna say,
thank you, very much to all these people who
support so that everybody can enjoy.
And if you would like to become one of them you
can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you wanna see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.